particular game if he steps the wrong
way or something to visit to Florida
State basketball said I was down for
whatever coach Hamilton underrated
passer doing a nice job in terms of the
total number of the quality of shots I'm
comfortable his only life is really good
for him right now he's in a good head
space coming in the handle
is maybe not as tough 20-point Advantage
this guy thinks he can do more
offensively the third and fourth periods
he always showed up to practice in a
uniform or work uniform
[Applause]
said very much still
the way he hangs in the air
[Applause]
check out with your Chicago here
he went one for two like the Raptors
loose ball Levine comes out of the pack
with it check out
oh wow Line Drive never made it make
sure they secured the defensive board
here if it comes off
[Applause]
with the rebound fouled by Scotty Barn